[Música]
Ucrania levantó la emergencia energética
que declaró tras la Nueva Ola de
bombardeos de Rusia los misiles
afectaron el suministro de agua en kiev
la capital e hicieron que la luz se
fuera en harky la segunda ciudad más
importante
la Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos visitará Perú el país andino
invitó al organismo y este confirmó su
presencia horas antes se anunció que la
cifra de muertos en las protestas tras
la detención del expresidente Pedro
Castillo subió a 18
24 conmemora el día del migrante que se
celebra el 18 de diciembre con una serie
de reportajes especiales hoy veremos el
capítulo de Qatar el país anfitrión de
la copa del mundo que ha sido señalado
de violar los derechos humanos de miles
de migrantes aun así el presidente de la
FIFA aseguró que defiende los Derechos
Humanos
Bienvenidos a las noticias de France 24
los saluda María Clara calle y es un
gusto acompañarlos iniciamos en Ucrania
el país sufrió uno de los peores ataques
por parte de Rusia desde que inició la
Guerra según las fuerzas militares
ucranianas la empresa Estatal eléctrica
ucra nergo Ya levantó la emergencia en
el sistema eléctrico que había declarado
este viernes Aunque sostuvo que los
bombardeos afectaron al 50% de la red
energética nacional más de 70 misiles
fueron lanzados sobre al menos cuatro
ciudades lo que aprendió las sirenas en
16 de las 24 regiones en kiev los
ataques afectaron el suministro de agua
y en harquif se fue totalmente la
electricidad
uno de los mayores ataques rusos contra
Ucrania decenas de misiles Fueron
lanzados por parte de Moscú sobre kiev
los bombardeos fueron dirigidos contra
la red eléctrica nueva instalaciones
generadoras fueron dañadas a pesar del
temor por su vida Los residentes en la
capital refugiados en el metro no
rendían su ánimo ante los embates del
kremlin
Mientras tanto quedó sin suministro
eléctrico
no sabemos nada internet está apagado y
no hay conexión no sabemos nada pero la
gente está saliendo nosotros lo
intentaremos también la estrategia de
Moscú está planteada aprovechar el
invierno como arma segunda
atacar nuestra infraestructura
energética hacer sufrir a la gente
durante el invierno es un genocidio
contra nuestra nación pero debo admitir
que nuestra moral Es realmente fuerte y
nunca nos rendiremos
lucharemos hasta por cada centímetro de
nuestro territorio bajo el control de
nuestro gobierno y podremos devolverle
una vida normal a nuestra gente
y permitirles vivir en paz y prosperidad
como colosales al menos 60 de los
proyectiles fueron derribados por las
defensas antiaéreas con el jefe de las
tropas ucranianas
la Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos hará una primera visita a Perú
del 19 al 21 de diciembre para estudiar
la situación del país donde ya se
registran 18 muertos en medio de las
manifestaciones el organismo condenó
desde el 9 de diciembre los hechos de
violencia que ha habido en las protestas
contra la destitución y detención del
expresidente Pedro Castillo también
llamaron a un diálogo serio entre las
instituciones y la sociedad ayer
Castillo le pidió a la cidh que
interceda por él luego de que la Corte
Suprema los sentenciara a 18 meses de
prisión preventiva
la cidh anuncia que aceptó la invitación
formal por parte del Estado para
realizar una visita al país expresando
su disponibilidad para una visita
técnica de la secretaría ejecutiva del
19 al 21 de diciembre y una Segunda
visita del relator país en enero del
hoy se cumplen tres meses de la muerte
de la joven Max a mini quien falleció
bajo la custodia de la policía de la
moral desde ese 12 de septiembre en Irán
ha habido protestas sin pausa y sin
precedentes mientras el gobierno habla
de 200 muertos organizaciones sociales
dicen que son cerca de 500
Pese a que inició hace tres meses la
revuelta en Irán no se ha debilitado y
el régimen ha endurecido su represión el
lema mujer vida libertad sigue resonando
tras la muerte de madsamini detenida
tres días antes de su fallecimiento por
la policía de la moral por llevar el
velo de manera supuestamente inapropiada
a la vanguardia de esta revuelta los
estudiantes iraníes que se organizan de
manera informal en internet en ausencia
de un líder como en estas imágenes en
una universidad de Terán
a los estudiantes se unieron en su lucha
minorías étnicas iraníes pero también
comerciantes y trabajadores que
respondieron a las convocatorias de
huelga general lo que debilitó aún más
la economía del país
Durante los últimos días los iraníes
también han celebrado marchas
silenciosas por todo el país como aquí
en
taris el 4 de diciembre Un anunció hizo
que el gobierno iraní diera Un paso
atrás el fiscal general anunció la
disolución de la policía de la moral la
misma que había detenido a maxa a mini
pero tras el anunció la represión va en
aumento desde el inicio de la revuelta
el 16 de septiembre entre 14 y 17,000
manifestantes han sido detenidos las
fuerzas de seguridad y arañas han matado
a más de cuatrocientas personas entre
ellas unos 60 niños un seis personas han
sido condenadas a muerte dos ya han sido
ejecutadas
de 23 años primer manifestante ahorcado
en público según amnistía internacional
varias decenas de iraníes más podrían
correr la misma suerte desde el comienzo
de la revuelta miles de civiles han sido
detenidos sin embargo algunos han sido
liberados como esta joven iraní de 17
años que en estas imágenes está ya de
alegría al salir de prisión confianza se
enfrentaba a la pena de muerte por
último 47 periodistas están encarcelados
en Irán tres veces más que el año pasado
en las redes sociales los estudiantes
cuelgan fotos de cuerdas está va
acompañada de un mensaje la esperanza no
será ejecutada
en otras noticias el presidente de la
FIFA ya ni infantino volvió a defender
al Mundial de Qatar en medio de las
críticas dos días antes de la final
aseguró que este es el mejor mundial de
todos y le agradeció al país anfitrión
Qatar esto a pesar de que fuentes de
seis gobiernos afirman que por lo menos
6.500 migrantes murieron entre 2010 y
2020 en el París en el país árabe
construyendo la infraestructura para la
copa del mundo
como dije para mí para nosotros cada
pérdida de Vidas es una tragedia y todo
lo que pudimos hacer para cambiar la
legislación para proteger la salud de
los trabajadores para proteger la
situación de los trabajadores lo hicimos
y sucedió lo que sea que podamos hacer
para el futuro lo estamos haciendo
seguimos trabajando en eso tuvimos
varias discusiones y estamos muy cerca
de llegar a acuerdos esto sucederá en
enero ciertamente un memorando de
entendimiento con la organización
laboral internacional Porque queremos
traer esta experiencia para el futuro y
asegurarnos que podemos ayudar podemos
aprovechar la copa del mundo y los focos
que están en la copa del mundo y el
fútbol en general para mejorar un poco
la vida de las personas y sus familias
a propósito de la polémica los migrantes
de varios países de Asia y África
representaron una fuerza laboral
fundamental para la construcción de los
del mundial de Qatar en nuestro quinto
episodio de la serie de reportajes sobre
el Día del migrante les contamos algunas
de las denuncias
llegaron a acatar con la esperanza de
construir una vida mejor solo el hijo de
este hogar en Duelo regreso de vuelta a
esta pequeña casa al sur de India la
familia cayó 10 uno de los tantos
hogares que acusan al Estado anfitrión
de la Copa del Mundo de las malas
condiciones laborales y los abusos
durante la construcción de los estadios
de fútbol
pensé que tendríamos días Buenos pensé
que la compañía era buena pero Dios
maldijo nuestra vida mi esposo murió
cuando estaba vivo enviaba dinero empecé
a construir esta casa y recién estábamos
acabando de edificar las vigas cuando
murió
katara ha enfrentado duras críticas por
las muertes lesiones e incumplimiento de
salarios a trabajadores extranjeros el
90% de las 2,8 millones de personas que
viven en el país árabe son migrantes la
mayoría provienen de países como India
bangladesh nepal Kenia o Filipinas
[Música]
6.500 trabajadores fallecidos fue la
cifra que sacudió al mundo un dato
suministrado por el diario de Guardian
que luego las autoridades de doja
contrastaron con tan solo 34 muertes de
forma oficial de las cuales sólo tres
adjudicaron a un accidente laboral los
funcionarios cataríes acusan a los
críticos de ignorar las reformas y
aplicar un doble rasero a la primera
nación árabe en albergar el Torneo Pues
aseguran el país del Golfo ha
introducido importantes reformas para
mejorar la seguridad de los trabajadores
y castigar a los empleadores que violen
las reglas sin embargo tiempo después un
alto funcionario catarí reconoció la
muerte de muchos más
la estimaciones de alrededor de 400
entre 400 y 500 no tengo el número
Exacto eso es algo que está sucediendo
una muerte ya es mucho así de simple sin
embargo creo que cada año mejoran las
normas de salud y seguridad en las obras
como la familia calladitos todavía
esperan los restos de sus familiares y
la respuesta de un país se construyó la
gloria los estadios bajo la tragedia de
miles de migrantes
hasta aquí las noticias sigan con
nosotros
[Música]